un went to welcome to video yeah I was
kind of hoping for oli gas for number
four thousand but if it didn't happen
he's online
so that was a likelihood that it
happened but it didn't okay playing hell
nah here I was here now no so we have a
modern defensive and we go h3 just that
not sure if I have to it cannot be
terrible maybe it can be terrible
it should be three mm it's probably
correct but okay normal development
cannot be all that bad in this position
yeah
video number four thousands been a long
road four thousand blitz games let's
develop I hope to not totally screw it
up if for that anniversary video let's
not do something stupid age six
yeah night night to and who I am is
something that I rather should have
maybe prevented but I don't I don't
think it's it's terrible for me if he
goes down my development is really a bit
too good for it to be a real issue so I
put it here I mean he's still suffering
a little bit here from lack of space
Bishop on d7
I'm just going to central I see activate
pieces and see what happens
bishop see - maybe h4 h5 that could be
in a constructive plan okay so he opens
it up yes I'm better developed
I don't mind it all that much 94 can
also do this first be ready for night f1
then see form push push black it back
push black back wow really
that looks loose
[Music]
and this looks correct first of all and
then see with the queen and doesn't have
many squares in the first place take
them and see for how does that not lose
stuff f5 midnight move just misses the
bishop
so probably f5 is the only move nope
okay so takes takes bishop takes and
then f5 okay
I have 96 though first that should have
at least wind exchange let's say so grab
it directly
should watch out for the time of course
maybe just Queen to e3 and ask him about
the Queen trade it's it's difficult not
to trade he can go to a five and a half
Queenie five so we treat Queens let's
let's do that and just play this play
this simplified position looks good
keep it simple don't want to screw up
that that anniversary game that same
so before b5 maybe it could this is
always not easy to say if you want to do
this or not
before b5 that looks good I wonder if I
should know play those simple moves him
yeah thought he would mostly misplace
the rope here a way to my room could be
misplaced there must be a bit cautious
there but here I have before b5 that
that should be the material right before
b5 is he taking on if true it seems to
be but it's not enough check
it's not enough so Bishop reform is
probably easiest Radio check
okay reasonably confident that I'm not
losing number 4,000 check black reside
yes
I would have liked it beyond 2400
reading but I didn't manage I mean I'm
kind of stuck in this region at the
moment yeah thanks a lot for watching
this game number four thousand let's
have a quick look at some points here
and see if how things were working
around I think this wasn't all that
dangerous I probably would have gone
here not to eat for as the engine
suggests but yeah why not put it on
active square took a little bit exposed
to have it it seems to be okay I push up
g3 was stronger already but it is a nice
position anyway c4 c5 was good young but
I'm slightly surprised how bad this
already is according to the engine I
mean I thought why it should be bit I
mean more than a bit better but then
you're basically says he can it is it's
just lost it probably is okay yeah okay
add this
this wasn't it was easier but okay so
it's not bad to take the exchange and
just play this this technical position
you know not reasonably happy I think I
didn't allow anything serious to happen
to to do to danger let's say the window
okay guys thanks for watching